welcome to our webinar on the five keys
to digital transformation in banking now
if in second ecommerce Giants are
disrupting the banking industry and time
is running out to achieve digital
maturity today's webinar can help
accelerate your transformation our guest
today is jennifer Borchardt vice
president of omni-channel experience and
strategy at US bank wealth management
who will be discussing the current state
of digital transformation in banking how
other banks have already gained digital
maturity are actually working a way to
achieve it and five things every Bank
needs to do to become digital ready it
is my pleasure to introduce you all to
Jennifer Borchardt she is the vice
president of omni-channel experience and
strategy for US bank wealth management
she was previously the vice president of
UX strategy Wells Fargo where she led
the evolution of Bank brokerage and
wealth management experience including
digital channels in innovation she was
also the lead producer at etrade where
she led the design and localization of
each raise international websites and
she was the on-site principal in the
company's European offices and worked
with the teams in Australia Europe Asia
and South Africa so I can't imagine a
better guest to have to talk about
digital transformation hello Jennifer
my pleasure the digital transformation
craze seems to be a little slow and the
banking side from what I've read and I
think the biggest risk from that that
I've been seeing is all of this brand
new competition so what's going on in
the world today that makes it even more
critical than ever for banks to get on
the ball thanks just like a lot of other
organizations need to need to meet
customers where they are and these
customers have embraced digital and
especially mobile many large banks as
well as smaller fintechs
really any any large commercial company
some small businesses everyone is going
digital and it is important for banks
especially to to serve the needs of
their users and be able to provide the
products and services that they expect
imagine a lot has that has to do with
like the age of your customers users
especially younger users who are digital
natives
their ex but there are expectations
about the experience how they expect
things to work are being shaped by
context including acorns Robin Hood and
venmo as well as companies outside of
financial services these companies
include Apple Facebook Instagram Google
and swipe apps I'm sure a lot of people
know know what I'm referring to
and so what's what's important to note
here is that when banks are looking to
to competitively Excel they need to look
not only with their direct at their
direct competitors but really every
place where people are spending their
time and forming their digital life
forming their expectations about digital
experiences right and I think the
biggest risk is that a lot of e-commerce
companies they daemon social media
companies are so much better at
engagement and that's the name of the
game and so that's a lot of catching up
to do
tech companies especially fintechs are
better at engagement because their
experiences have been designed centered
on users from the very start they have
the latest information about cognitive
psychology usability accessibility and
behavioral economics this is this this
is all baked into their experiences and
their strategy from the very beginning
where as experiences from larger
institutions and this does not just
include banks these these experiences
have evolved over time based on legacy
experiences and legacy systems however
many large companies and especially
banks they are now heavily investing in
user research technology and new
methodologies including agile for
digital transformation and creating more
user centric experiences to increase
engagement in user satisfaction so this
is this is actually very encouraging
some of these larger organizations and
banks that have previously legs in in
digital readiness and digital experience
they're now starting to catch up with
major investments more than half of
consumers would be comfortable using a
technology company such as Apple or
Google for various types of financial
transactions
and and JD Power and Associates said
that that digital-only customers now
account for almost a third of retail
bank clientele a lot of customers prefer
to interact with their financial
organizations by digital and that's
compared to 34% who prefer branch
interactions so only about a third of
branch customers prefer to come into the
bank and so they're kind of it would
seem that they're losing their advantage
in terms of the brick-and-mortar aspect
of branches that's not actually the
entire story um regarding digital it's a
channel of choice this is definitely
true for certain types of activities
including viewing balances transferring
money and depositing checks the basics
of financial management but other types
of transactions including opening and
closing accounts or handling something
more complicated like a fraud event
owned and branch are still still tend to
be the preferred channels however as
technical capabilities in customers
comfort with using technology improves
more of these complicated interactions
are going to move to digital right I've
see some other statistics up here about
how 44 percent of Gen Z consumers
anticipate supplementing their
traditional banking services or the
solutions from technology companies and
that 43 percent of customers regularly
use mobile banking and that customers
who don't use their bank's mobile apps
are twice as likely to be dissatisfied
and not recommend that Bank and that's
something we're gonna be talking about
later but as far as customer experience
and that it isn't just about having a
bank website or even mobile banking so
let's talk about where banks are today
how prepared are they are they from what
I've seen they're lagging behind can you
update us large organizations because of
their complexity because of their size
because of their legacy experiences and
systems I I think it is fair to say that
they are behind but behind relative to
what many many fintechs many many
startups they're already farther ahead
because they kind of got a head start
they they they were built digital first
and so thanks
are making large investments in changing
their culture changing the way that they
that they invest in technology and their
people and they are catching up and I
would actually say that the disparity
between large banks and fintechs one way
that this is going to to start to narrow
is that as fintechs kind of hit the
ceiling of what they're capable of
Pentax are great for doing limited types
of transactions as they start to hit the
limit on what they're able to do and
they can't grow any further a lot of
this has to do with regulations banks
and fintechs
are going to start partnering right this
could be acquisition or this this could
be a partnership and so through these
partnerships both the large banks and
the smaller fintechs will be able to do
what they do best and be able to rely on
the strengths of the others I donation
that partnership is important
particularly for the fintechs too
because I know that the banking industry
is so regulated that it would take a lot
for the fintechs to really catch up to
that compliance so imagine working with
it so it's the who's the e-commerce and
fin tech startups to partner as well
yeah and in complaints with these these
very complicated in arcane regulations
is is really a barrier to entry some
some smaller companies in this this
isn't just in financial services this is
also in transportation goober and lyft
are great examples and Airbnb too in
fact their their approach has been to
just either go under the radar or take
the approach of asking forgiveness
rather than permission and of course as
these if these companies are getting
larger expanding their reach
getting getting the notice of of local
and local federal government's they're
starting to now have to comply with
regulations just as their larger
competitors do and that is evening the
playing field so to speak right but as
far as leveling the playing field I know
a lot of banks think that they just have
to put an interface out that it isn't
just about user experience it isn't just
about a website and the digital bank
report from Adobe said that most banks
and
unions have simply put a nice veneer on
legacy systems and products ignoring
many of the internal changes that are
needed to compete effectively with the
smaller fintechs
and it's nice to see if that's beginning
to change I know a lot of these changes
have to do with a cultural shift at the
top and I know a perfect example of this
is JPMorgan Chase and company where the
CEO has made it a mission to go digital
first so let's talk about what it takes
to make that cultural shift digital
capabilities are very important and
transformation readiness goes well
beyond technology which of course has
its costs and challenges the cultures
arguably the more difficult barrier and
these these challenges are not happening
only at large banks but also at other
medium and large organizations across
many industries beyond financial
services we need healthcare technology
utilities in retail one one thing that
comes to mind I was on a panel talking
about agile transformation and and I met
a leader from Pacific Gas and Electric
PG&E and it was really interesting to
hear that that PG&E was experiencing a
lot of the same challenges transforming
to agile as as the very large Bank where
I work interesting now what's
interesting is that the cultural shift
isn't just about a CEO saying we need to
transform it it requires a commitment
that goes right down to the deepest
levels including funding and talent
acquisition and developing that talent
and developing agile workflows and
empowering teams to make decisions and
the willingness do make risks and the
budget to back it up and I know that
risk-taking and banking is always a
something that is it is a riskier thing
to do in banking then and many other
companies so I imagine that may be
what's a what was it been a big barrier
yes thanks thanks have historically been
been a little bit risk-averse and some
of some of this has to do with the with
the culture and some of this has to do
with the regulations
regulations they're not they're not
getting getting any simpler um
digital transformation particularly if
it includes adopting and adults about
limb methodology which I know we'll be
talking about later this is this is this
is one of the biggest keys this
transformation to be successful requires
distributed decision-making which in
which requires empowering lower-level
team members to make decisions the
reason why this is challenging and
especially in larger more established
organizations the types of decision most
decision making tends to be centralized
at the top and so making that shift
having leaders I give up give up their
their decision-making abilities is
something something which which is hard
for a lot of people to do they are human
beings after all and in order to make
the this lower level decision-making
successful it's critical to recruit
develop and retain people who know how
to make the right decisions and are able
to thrive in agile environments shifting
these hiring practices to to enable that
type of organization is neither simple
nor fast right one wait a lot of
companies have found to make things
simpler and faster is to embrace an
agile methodology I think before we talk
about how to do it's also important to
understand where a gel works best in
where where there there's some there's
some improvements to be made the agile
manifesto and the methodologies that
respond from it were created by and for
software developers so it works very
well and organizations that are highly
focused on software this is this is a
lot of companies however a lot of
companies are not focused on software
banks are focus on something other than
software software empowers would
empowers their goals but it's not
central agile as it as it tends to be
implemented does not accommodate or
serve other practices quite as well as
it does software development things like
design and research these are very
critical elements to develop and go to
user experiences and empowering
successful digital transformations and
so
so the opportunity is really how do you
adopt agile how do you how do you adapt
it so it can also accommodate ideation
research design and and even even in
innovation run allowing allowing
business leaders to to come up with in
test ideas edged out because of because
it moves quickly and you make very rapid
and frequent incremental changes it's
actually very well-suited to design and
research it's just a matter of applying
it in the right way
right and one of the best ways to apply
it is in improving customer service so
let's talk about the importance of
customer experience because I know
that's that's pivotal to your role at US
bank yes it's been pivotal my entire
career in fact so several years ago user
experience was the hot topic and many
organizations started to recognize the
importance of good experiences to
customer acquisition retention and
satisfaction you need customers to have
a successful business has a user
experience correct I do know the value
of good experience and I was so
encouraging for me to see top level sea
level leaders enthusiastically embracing
and supporting user experience now this
enthusiasm is shifting to agile and
digital transformation but these leaders
are seeing that like good user
experience digital transformation and
agile adoption does not just happen it
needs focused in informed effort and
vision exactly how to make this happen
however is still elusive to many
companies but they are learning although
sometimes slowly right I know that more
than half of clients view digital as a
number one factor in England in
influencing their client service
experience and so a lot of people are
really catching on to this another thing
is about how the this is one of the
advantages that I think that banks have
over a lot of Finn's X's because banks
have so much data and they've had it
from legacy systems for decades and and
that's a lot to catch up with once
they're able to tap into all this data
and use it using machine learning and
other tools it can really improve
customer journeys in the way that other
cannot even touch for example using
customer data deliver the
personalization needed for superior
customer experience and value like
actually making on-the-spot their
recommendations and being able to
predict consumer behavior and anticipate
their needs and then provide offers at
the right time which is the perfect way
to do not just marketing but actually
service your clients because machine
learning can discover customer patterns
that enable the future predictions and
either product offers that are hard for
humans to anticipate because they can
see clusters that we can't so tell us a
little bit about that so banks have no
shortage of user data but the challenge
is how to extract order and value from
these very very large sets of data and
use it to create meaningful timely and
personalized experiences it's AI in meat
in machine learning learning advances
there were more opportunities to not
only identify but also predict customers
needs based on their behavior and what
and what they already know about them
for example a bank may notice that a
customer keeps a high stable balance in
a savings account with this information
the bank could then recommend that the
user transfer their money to a money
market account with a higher interest
rate or even invest the cash in an
investment account a self-directed
brokerage account or a Robo advisor this
this benefits the customer by giving
them higher return on their money but it
also benefits the bank by an empowering
a deeper more valuable relationship and
increase in customer loyalty customers
feel like my bank knows me and they have
my best interest in mind this is even
more powerful as it happens over the
life of a customer's relationship with
their bank moving up providing the right
products and services at the right point
over the customers journey for example a
student and her family get student loans
from a bank to pay for college then the
student opens her first checking account
gets her first credit card as she starts
college in time these loans are paid off
and she gets a mortgage perhaps a small
loan to pay for a wedding then a few
years later she starts a 529 plan for
her kids education and the cycle
continues this is this is how banks can
use data and life events to serve
clients over their entire life in their
entire financial journey terrific now we
have one question how should we go about
improving customer service or whether
you want to improve the time on the site
or to optimize it so let's talk about
both those things I think the heart of
this is serving the customer in the best
way make sense that somebody doesn't
want to spend more time thinking than
they have to thinking tends to be very
task oriented and and oftentimes very
time-sensitive and so what we want to do
is not necessarily to maximize the
amount of time that they spend on the
site by making things go more slowly but
we want to make the most most of the
time that they that they do spend so
figuring out what people do the most
making it easy for them checking their
balances transferring money paying their
bills if they're an investor placing a
trade checking on the status of their
order we want to make it easy
frictionless and pleasant there is a way
to increase customer engagement though
and to increase the time on the site but
we want additional time on the site to
be because we are serving a customer's
need not because we're making it harder
for them to get through what they need
right one example is that providing
contextual educational content
someone's looking at their balances they
may notice a link to an article about
investing or about preparing for tax
time or something something which is
meaningful to a customer and so that
their we give the user a relevant
opportunity to spend more time with us
to learn and so is so instead of this
additional time on our site or on our
app being a frustration we're actually
providing value and deepening the
relationship it's time well spent
right now they should be on your site
longer because they want to be yes not
because they can't find what they're
looking for we don't want to hold them
hostage we want them to to stay with us
a little bit longer because because it
pleases them reminds me of the old days
when banks would have
cookies and have little entertainment
things going on in the lobby just to
keep them in the lobby longer very much
like that well-written educational
articles are today's Lobby cookies mmm
let's talk about mobile particularly
digital banking being much more than
having a mobile app let's take a look at
the advantage of having mobile apps
frequent users of banks mobile apps are
the most satisfied more than
three-quarters would recommend their
bank to others let's talk about another
aspect of mobile banking
it really helps banks do something that
banks have been trying to do for decades
which is reach 20% of the population
that is unbanked or underbanked see I'd
like to revisit satisfaction as it
relates to mobile usage I think that's
very important increased satisfaction
with mobile app usage could be due to a
couple of factors first thanks for
making a lot of investment in their
mobile technology in their employing
user centered design approaches so user
satisfaction is kind of baked in second
customers who download their bank's
mobile app they may already have a
higher level of trust and satisfaction
with their bank customers need to make
an active choice to download a mobile
banking app in most cases um they need
to make a decision these apps are not
pre-loaded onto your phones however
Google pay Google Google pays preloaded
into many new Android phones where an
apple pays already part of iOS and
iPhones this too actually presents a
challenge to banks in their mobile apps
it's easier it's less friction to use
something that's already embedded and
where you are already in your advice so
so banks do need to take the extra step
to make people know that it's going to
be worth their while to download their
apps absent such a short life span a lot
of people only have apps on their phone
for a day in order to use whatever it is
they're doing and so and only use about
a handful of apps regularly to so it's
really places a lot more emphasis on
banks to make it engaging yes and also
when people upgrade their devices and I
actually I think this is this is a
really cool feature as a mobile device
user when you upgrade your phone a lot
of time
you're able to bring your apps with you
from your old phone and so that actually
increases the friction of downloading
new apps which makes it even more
important for people for banks to create
apps that are useful that people want to
connect with and stay connected with
another another interesting topic of
customer satisfaction and this isn't
necessarily to mobile to mobile apps but
it is related to banking customers
who've had negative experiences such as
fraud which is a really stressful
experience these negative experience has
have been positively resolved by their
banks these clients report a higher
level of satisfaction the customers
who've never had such bad experiences so
I I thought that was that was really
interesting and it also touches on
something I talked about before right
now to take care of a stressful fraud
event you need it's much easier much
better to go to go to a branch or by
phone but again as as banks technology
is evolving even even these very
complicated high stakes events will
eventually be able to be fully
self-service using digital channels
right I'm sure it really places a lot of
emphasis on the live customer service
aspect to understand every part of the
digital channel that the customers have
gone through this so they can understand
what what they went through in in the
course of that that fraud event or any
other customer service issue yeah
digital especially mobile banking is a
really important way that people connect
with their banks but we do need to
remember that this is not the only way
recently banks have invested very
heavily in online and mobile banking but
now they need to take a step back and
consider how the digital channel works
across the entire ecosystem across the
experience across all channels and this
includes ATMs phones branches and as
much as possible this experience needs
to be consistent and supportive across
channels and customers need to be able
to use their channel of choice when they
want
for what they want mmm mobile apps are a
great way to reach underserved baking
populations yes so mobile banking is
critical it's it's valuable to a lot of
people but in some cases it's a lifeline
for unbanked and underbanked populations
smart phones especially androids are
ubiquitous because they're portable
they're easy to get in they're more
economical than than computers there are
a lot of people who have have a
smartphone maybe even the newest
smartphone but don't have a computer at
home
I actually am effectively one of those
people I used to live on my laptop and
now I know I hardly use it I just used
my smartphone and because because of
this behavioral shift this has affected
how designers create mobile experiences
rather how they approach their
experiences when we when we take into
account where a lot of these unbanked
and underbanked people are they're not
using iPhones they may be using old
iPhones and that's actually very
important so when when mobile banking
first became a thing the earliest mobile
apps were designed for only iOS iPhones
were the first widely adopted smartphone
and they work but they tended to be
owned mostly by affluent people now as
Android dominates the market dominates
market share because phones running
Android are all over they're cheap or
free and they're plentiful this is true
in the US and all over the world so so
now designers are are having to think
about how does this work on Android how
does this work on a variety of devices
especially older devices as people are
keeping them longer more rather than
just designing for the very latest
device at the very um at at a particular
time so so more more and more bank
customers are becoming mobile only this
shift has also affected where we can
look to for behavioral trends in banking
American banks used to look to develop
countries in Europe and Asia for the
future of Technology in banking
technology and banking innovations were
adopted there first they were developed
there they were sometimes years ahead of
when these technologies became
widespread in the u.s. huh this was the
future of American financial services
however as the unbanked and underbanked
populations grow in this country in
other parts of the world especially
especially with increasing number of
immigrants who regardless of their
documentation status they have lives to
live and business they need to conduct
they need to send money to the friends
and family they need to pay their bills
and for these people fintechs and
accessible technology rather than big
banks enable these activities so
developing countries in Africa and
Central America for example can show us
how these extra banking financial
systems can operate at scale large
populations using very simple mobile
phones and very simple payment
applications many many of us may take
this for granted but there are really
important things to learn and I believe
this is only going to become more
relevant to sign goes on mmm-hmm well
let's look at advantages that banks have
which is the branch and this is one way
in addition to having all of this data
on consumers is that banks have the
advantage of the branch and how can they
branch out and um is that to increase
their foothold in the digital world is
so um different channels are better
suited for different types of activities
in many times multiple channels are
being used concurrently someone who
walks into a branch may have very
specialized needs they may have an
established relationship with their with
their banker and so branches definitely
do serve a purpose
however the branch visit of today looks
very different than the branch visits
just a few years ago a few years ago
people may may have walked into a branch
talked directly to to a banker and then
and then leave but what happens today is
actually actually more omni-channel
somebody a customer walks into a branch
with their smartphone running the mobile
app of that bank there their teller
their banker they are face to face at a
desk or
perhaps sitting side-by-side and the
teller or the banker has has an
application on their tablet and so now
you have the in-person experience you
have the mobile experience that the the
client is is taking pardon and at the
very same time you have a tablet
application that the banker is using and
all of these things are working together
to to serve the customer in the best
possible way I would say the biggest
advantage that branches provide is the
human connection no matter how advanced
technology isn't matter how intelligent
AI becomes nothing is ever going to
fully replace the human connection
that's probably why majority of US
customers feel that online-only banks
are somehow less legitimate and that
even Millennials and Gen zere's prefer
to walk into a bank and talk to person
when they're doing something like
opening an account yes or and here's a
personal use case getting a cashier's
check to put a deposit on an apartment
or or buying a car I my my primary bank
is this is almost completely branchless
there are two branches in the entire
country what happens to be here in San
Francisco the others in New York and 99
percent of the time this is just fine
but when I needed to have it to have a
cashier's check for something I went to
another large Bank a competitor and
opened an account and I keep this
account because branch is an in person
in person relationships sort of you know
an irreplaceable purpose and this is
especially important for people who
cannot use technology who are not
familiar with technology older people
and people who have very high value
relationships with their financial
institutions an app isn't going to pop
them about succession planning about how
they're going to manage their millions
of dollars and even though many many
people may not be able to relate to that
right now it is something that's very
important it's it's
very important to bank certainly because
these are very valuable clients but
being able to provide a personal
experience that touches on the emotion
of human connection is something which
which banks know apply to everybody and
that's something that's going to be
really hard for AI to replace yeah
certainly it also explains why the
highest overall satisfaction comes from
branch dependent digital customers this
was the interesting thing that I heard
from McKinsey was saying that for
uncommon financial institutions the
biggest hurdles relate to organizational
organization and skills as much as
investing in technology at scale so with
that being highlighted as one of the
problems let's talk about how things can
improve these skills gaps yeah I think I
think one way that ace can improve these
scull gaps is by is by training their
team members to to embrace technology to
learn about technology so they
themselves as team members are
understand how technology works but are
also able to help their clients
understand how technology works and
adopt it and again relationships in
human emotion and connectivity this is
something which technology can never
really replace and so in so developing
soft skills leadership skills
organizational skills communication
these are all very important it's also
important for banks to invest in
training further further for their team
members learning about agile learning
about different different types of
Technology applications learning about
how to do how to create a good user
experience and good user experience is
for everybody it's not just designers
it's not just me and my team but
everyone has has a stake and good
experience and this is and this is the
type of training which banks should
invest in for their key members but
individuals should also invest in it for
themselves as they do as they explore
their
personal professional development right
so that include things like courses in
design thinking design thinking
absolutely
project management becoming an agile
scrum master getting you're getting your
PMP certification but you know in in
addition to training just learning how
to communicate with other people
learning how to connect with other
people huh yeah that's terrific now I
think we're coming to the end of our
prepared portion and the so we'll invite
people to provide their own questions at
this point too but just to sum up
because we talked about there are five
keys do digital transformation and
banking that relies on making a cultural
shift from the sea level down learning
from the successive failures of other
organizations that are trying to
transform transitioning the agile
methodology beyond IT when it's
applicable in a banking situation and it
isn't always the case but there are many
areas outside of software development
that agile can help of course focusing
on customer experience and making it
better at all touch points from the
outgoing message and the voicemail to
the branch to the apps and beyond
and finally bridging internal skills
gaps in digital capabilities through
training incumbent employees and that
includes not just digital skills but
design thinking and human capabilities
to make people much more personable to
be able to prove that social aspect that
banks worthy bring to all people yes and
getting training in data science if this
is something that you're interested in
has never hurt anybody in fact I think
this is probably one of the most
important fields not just in banking but
but for anything data is going to drive
so many decisions so many experiences in
shape a lot of organizations so that is
that is also a wonderful area to explore
the training what are some things that a
smaller bank can do to bring their staff
up to speed most quickly it's a
with this transformation well investing
in technology certainly even though a
smaller bank may not have the same large
training budget as as a large bank there
are a lot of free and very affordable
resources online in libraries or not
only executives but also the lowest
level team members to learn about
digital transformation this is a topic
that's in the news people are talking
about all over the place and
individuals in and banks alike can take
advantage of this do you have any
recommendations to help make a cultural
shift how do you manage upwards in order
to speed this transition along in terms
of the cultural shift in terms of
managing up executives rely a lot on
data and so providing providing data to
rationalize your recommendations showing
what competitors are doing how they're
doing it and this is something which is
often missing from competitive analysis
how can these best practices seen
elsewhere apply to a particular
organization justjust because it works
for company 8 doesn't mean it's going to
work within companies beat culture cups
are a company B's culture or company B's
tech technology infrastructure and so
taking that extra step providing
thoughtful analysis in some in action
and actionable recommendations is going
to go a very long way in influencing
leadership right now someone is asking
what's the difference between business
transformation and digital
transformation can you talk to that or
oh yes this is business transformation I
would say is larger it's more
overarching whereas digital
transformation is more focused it's
focused more on the digital channel it's
focused more on the technology and
services that that support the digital
channel but business transformation
includes more of the cultural shift that
is necessary to ensure a successful
digital transformation and one of the
big things one of the big pieces of that
again is decision making have empowering
people to make decisions and empowering
people to take more ownership of what
happens day to day instead of just
following following directions they have
a stake in the business they have they
have a stake in the decisions in this
this not only results in better user
experiences but it also results in
better team member experiences people
are more likely to be happy satisfied
long-term employees if they feel like
they have a stake right and control over
what's happening excellent let's talk
about branches are they are they going
away no but they are changing in San
Francisco there are a couple of very
large banks who have piloted the
branches of the future branches which
used to be large and plentiful there now
there are fewer of them in the ones that
that remain are smaller but they they
actually provide I would say better
service elite at least better service
for for people who are connected to
digital like a lot of us are so there is
a branch on the Main Street in San
Francisco on Market Street it used to be
very large now it's about a third of the
size but there's a lot more you can do
there
there are ATMs that that dispense change
roles which is very important if you're
a business yeah there are fewer tellers
there but the tellers that are there can
do a lot more they are well versed in
more areas of the business but they also
have these very powerful applications on
their tablets that they carry around
with them and they can engage directly
with customers who come in customers or
prospects even people who aren't yet we
don't have yet a relationship with the
bank they're able to do a lot more and
they're using digital to increase how
much they can service their customers
and the quality of that service any
predictions for the future like even in
branches like I've seen some ideas as
far as computerized kiosks not just ATMs
and lobbies where you have a live person
on the other end are there any other or
describe a little bit about that or any
other trends you kind of see down the
pike because we have a retreat here is
that we have an inside person who can
tell us what's uh what's what's looking
forward that's actually not the future
that is happening now and there's
another large Bank who has video chats
with tellers this is something with
which they've had much they've had for a
few years and it's it's really it's
really great it's really neat to see it
so in this video chat over mobile right
over no we actually have these screens
or by iPhone in the lobby
they're actually in the lobby you walk
in and if you want to talk to a banker
live then you can do that but instead of
the banker needing to be at that
physical location they can be anywhere
it's their centralized and these bankers
can service people all over the country
wherever Reverend these these video
kiosks exist and so someone can can go
in there and that could be the primary
interaction or maybe they're at the ATM
you run into a problem they have a
question that an ATM can't answer but
they can then then go to the video kiosk
and talk to a banker in real-time and
get and get what they need mhm
it's very powerful we're running to the
end of our time here so I just wanted to
say thank you again
Jennifer Borchardt for joining us today
and we look forward to talking to you
again in the future
thank you
[Music]